numéro départ nous avons voulu faire une
revue de réflexion pour qu'on puisse
dire qu'on était souverain sans être
forcément un nationaliste dans quelqu'un
belliqueux et puis par la suite on s'est
aperçu qu'on avait un afflux
considérable de lecteurs d'abonnés on a
passé les trente mille abonnés alors que
la revue n'était même pas encore en
kiosque et que personne ne l'a vu et on
s'est dit mais on a on a des obligations
on a des devoirs à l'endroit de ces
jeunes de ce genre donc si on fait
remonter des propositions il faut que
ces propositions puissent être
praticable et qu'ils puissent
éventuellement être pratiquée donc après
ça prendra la forme que ça devra prendre
on est des empirique
on n'est pas parti en se disant on va
faire émerger un candidat pour les
prochaines présidentielles mais si la
question se pose on examinera et puis
après tout pourquoi pas mais les
français n'ont pas envie d'un second
tour avec mâcon et marine le pen
donc si intellectuellement peut
contribuer à l'évitement de ce genre de
débat qui n'est pas un débat eh bien on
aura fait notre travail justement ce
candidat là on a compris que c'était pas
votre premier ambitions avec cette revue
contrairement encore une fois ce qui est
effectivement présent des dents dans
toute la presse l'ambition voilà d'un
programme de socle pour pour la
présidentielle en tout cas ce candidat
idéal vous le verriez comment est la
prochaine présidentielle notre aventure
on y autogestionnaire c'est à dire qu'on
pense qu'il ya un génie du peuple et que
s'il faut régler les problèmes de la
médecine il vaut mieux demander à des
médecins des infirmières des dames qui
travaillent ou à des hommes qui
travaillent dans les hôpitaux que pour
les pêcheries française pour la
paysannerie française pour l'université
l'éducation la recherche au fait il vaut
mieux aller demander aux gens qui sont
compétents parce qu'ils ont la pratique
et la connaissance de leur discipline
ce que sont la proposition plutôt que de
demander à des énarques à des gens qui
ont fait sciences po voit des gens qui
font de la politique un métier qui sont
dans la politique politicienne depuis
depuis des décennies de leur demander
leur avis nous notre modèle vous savez
dans l'histoire c'était dans les années
70 l'ips c'est à dire des gens qui
fabriquait des comptes et qui à un
moment donné se sont dit eh bien nous on
va autant gérer notre notre aventure est
aujourd'hui avec internet avec le site
que mâcon a lancé le jour du 18 janvier
par par hasard c'est notre appel à nous
et bien non on dit cette chute donc des
cahiers de doléances faisons des états
généraux perpétuelle ce que macro
indiqué que j'aurais kiné
et puis remontant quelque chose qui va
ressembler à un programme et puis après
si ce programme sert à tel ou tel
pourquoi pas et si un jour quelqu'un
sort de la société civile et qui peut
porter lui-même ce projet ce ne sera pas
moi je les dis eh bien on pourra
pourrait parler au conditionnel on
pourrait éventuellement l'aider mais a
priori notre revue n'est pas là pour
servir de tremplin à qui que ce soit
pour devenir un chef de l'état